bonjour et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur arte france qu'elles sont
là les intentions des états unis selon
vous dans le marquage à la culotte
réciproque et je pense aussi que dans ce
pays la norvège eux bonne élève de
l'otan lorsque vous présentiez tout à
l'heure je peux compléter en vous disant
que comme sénateur j'ai siégé à
l'assemblée parlementaire de l'otan donc
c'est des questions que j'ai suivie de
près et donc la norvège comme bonne
élève de l'otan et sociales au ministre
en étant d'ailleurs le secrétaire
général et bien le message c'est que
entre les administrations trump et
baydan malgré des changements par
ailleurs on veut marquer danville
temblay une continuité dans
l'affirmation de cette présence il faut
dire que il ya eu quand même
côté russe quelques entre guillemets
provocations y compris il ya encore
quelques mois et donc toute la question
derrière ces petits signaux qui
finalement ne prennent pas
conséquence c'est de savoir si on se
donne des conditions d'une normalisation
de leurs relations avec la russie sur
tous les plans ou si on est dans une
dans les prémices d'une période de
tensions durables
ce qui naturellement serait
problématique et puis enfin ça pose
comme chaque fois on cette intervention
américaine
la question de la défense européenne
compris ensemble sein de l'otan et de sa
capacité ou plutôt de son actuel
incapacité à assumer seul en tout cas si
mon seul du moins de manière principale
sa propre défense
voilà un peu ce que me fait dire cet
événement en soi mais hautement
symbolique alors pour revenir sur les
intentions américaines il est aussi
question de l'exploitation des
ressources naturelles dans l'arctique
c'est une priorité stratégique
gic aujourd'hui l'exécutif américain
franchement cette une priorité à moyen
terme pour l'ensemble des forces des
pays qui se partagent cette zone qui
sans partage la souveraineté et ça vaut
évidemment pour les russes comme pour
les américains et vous savez ces femmes
endroit où très facilement un sur un
loupé ce on peut déborder les secteurs
tels qu'ils ont été prévus par les
instances internationales compétentes et
je pense que là aussi la solution de la
bonne exploitation respectueuse
également des enjeux climatiques
lesquels d'ailleurs enjeux climatiques
peuvent amener avec le réchauffement
davantage de potentiel de l'exploitation
eh bien je pense que la bonne solution
c'est la négociation est ce que nous
sommes avec une administration qui se
veut raisonnable simplement dans un
petit signal à vos discussions
ou est ce que c'est quelque chose de
plus grave
moi je pencherais pour un signal avant
discussions car ses enjeux économiques
c'est l'enjeu de possibilité pour chacun
d'eux d'envisager cette dimension
économique dans le respect des principes
que je rappeler tout à l'heure ça passe
par la discussion
ça passe pas par tj permanent de la
tension évidemment alors vous évoquiez
l'union européenne il ya un instant ce
qu'il ya concertation sur ce dossier au
niveau européen concernant les
manoeuvres qui seront effectués il ya
forcément le concertation parce que même
si la défense européenne est encore on
sait dans ses balbutiements
elle commence tout de même à exister que
ce soit en matière stratégique
opérationnel d'armement en matière
également d'organisation au sein et en
lien avec le temps donc
oui forcément il y a concertation
forcément on est à l'aube d'une montée
en puissance progressive de la défense
européenne
encore une fois y compris au sein de
l'otan mais ça n'interdit pas non plus
côté européen le souci d'un nécessaire
dialogue avec la russie et notamment
d'ailleurs sur les questions économiques
la rosée qui ne fait donc pas partie des
concertations vous vous en parlait il ya
quelques instants
c'est ce que vous nous disiez c'est une
stratégie de la part des états unis
avant le échanges négociations pour les
européens et notamment les français
la russie n'est pas un allié sûr une
part stratégique mais la russie n'est
pas un ennemi
loin s'en faut la russie c'est la grande
europe la russie c'est un partenaire et
c'est petit et c'est potentiellement un
partenaire qui a vocation à être plus
important qu'il ne l'est aujourd'hui
mais on ne peut être un bon partenaire
avec là aussi que si on est capable de
porter un bon rapport de forces au
service d'une bonne capacité de dialogue
et de défense de ses intérêts bien
compris et je n'oublie jamais que la
défense de ses intérêts par chacun et
dans le respect des autres c'est le b à
ba de la diplomatie on n'a pas à être
des donneurs de leçons même si parfois
on alward passer les messages
on doit d'abord être la foi dans cette
recherche de nos propres intérêts et
dans la persistance du dialogue
même dans ces moments un peu tendue y
compris en coop ti cats à leur puce mais
ne mélangeons pas tout ça n'est pas le
faire merci beaucoup d'avoir prétendent
répondre à nos questions jean marie
bockel ancien secrétaire d'état à la
défense notamment
merci et à bientôt